This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个iHeart播客。百分之二。这是有电梯可乘时依然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个光怪陆离的现代世界中，如何培养心理韧性、保持健康以及建立恢复力。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在逆境之后变得更加快乐、更有成就感、更健康。请收听《2%》。也就是在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听“2”百分比播客。在《回顾过去》(Look Back at it)播客中。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是个重要的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。在每一集中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家一起。比如马马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。1984年真是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听“Look Back at it”。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯主持的《知难而退》(Learn the Hard Way)。这个空间聚焦黑人男性的经历，进行坦诚的对话，而这些对话在其他地方其实并不安全，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着一副盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你必须这么做。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听并了解“知难而退”。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg, a lesbian,
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。埃伦女士，你对这个特定的测试动了两次手脚，对吗？我只对测试动过一次手脚。这需要一支网络侦探大队才能揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个女同性恋者，
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我简直惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《受困于爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。收听《受困于爱》播客
on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed.
在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个惯犯骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。
will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is, as always, so great to have you here. About a quarter of us are struggling with our mental health in some way, whether it's a
将成为他的最后一个目标。他不会就这样逃脱惩罚的。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的好姐妹。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《闺蜜，相信我，宝贝》(The girlfriends. Trust me, babe)。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》(The psychology of your 20s)，这是一个探讨我们在二十岁时经历的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到这个播客。新听众、老听众，无论你身处世界的哪个角落。像往常一样，很高兴能有你们在这里。我们中大约四分之一的人在心理健康方面以某种方式苦苦挣扎，无论这是
very present thing in our day-to-day life or just kind of always there sitting silently in the background, that means that basically if you were to select four people in your office at your workplace on your train this morning, in a classroom, you know, if you were to select four people from a random friendship group or from a family, one of them would have a story about the way their mental health is a present figure in their life or something that they've dealt with. It's kind of a startling number when you think about it, 25% of people, but it's also very much true. Here's the thing though, for that one in four, each of those people would have about, you know, the average is five to, five to ten close friends. About 50% of them would have a partner.
在我们日常生活中非常真实的存在，还是只是某种总是默默潜伏在背景中的东西，这意味着基本上，如果你今天早上在办公室、工作场所、火车上、教室里随机挑选四个人，你知道的，如果你从一个随机的朋友圈或一个家庭中挑选四个人，其中一个人就会有一个关于他们的心理健康如何在他们的生活中扮演重要角色，或者他们一直在应对的事情的故事。当你仔细想想，这是一个相当惊人的数字，占人口的25%，但它也绝对是真实存在的。不过话又说回来，对于那四分之一的人来说，每个人大概都会有，你知道的，平均有五到十个密友。其中大约50%的人会有一个伴侣。
Most of us have some family that we would be close to. And so though, you know, although it's one quarter of us who may be struggling with our mental health and, you know, in what feels like a very solitary experience, there are millions, if not billions more who see someone they love, hurting, struggling, persevering, and they want to help, but sometimes just don't know how to, because who has ever taught them? When was that really ever included in a school curriculum? When was that a priority to teach us as children or as teenagers or ever how to help someone we love when they're struggling with their mental health? So today, my lovely listeners, that is exactly what we're talking about, whether it is someone that we're dating,
我们大多数人都有一些关系亲密的家人。因此，尽管（你知道的）我们中四分之一的人可能正在与心理健康问题作斗争，而且（你知道的）这感觉像是一个非常孤独的经历，但还有数百万甚至数十亿人看到他们爱的人在痛苦、在挣扎、在坚持，他们想要帮忙，但有时就是不知道该怎么做，因为谁曾教过他们这些呢？什么时候这些内容真的被纳入过学校的课程？什么时候教导我们作为儿童、青少年或在任何时候如何帮助一个正在与心理健康作斗争的我们爱的人，成为过优先事项呢？所以今天，我可爱的听众们，这正是我们要讨论的内容，无论是我们正在约会的人，
someone that we're in a relationship with, a friend, a family member. How do we help them with their own private struggles and battles that we just don't really know much about, that we don't have a guidebook to, even when we try our hardest to do our best? It can really be quite scary being this situation. I want to just say that first, like up front, first and foremost, because every fiber of you wants to fix what's going on. You see their distress. want to get rid of it. You want to find some way through, but we just don't know how. And sometimes
我们正在与之交往的人、朋友、还是家庭成员。我们该如何帮助他们应对他们私下的挣扎和战斗？对此我们其实并不太了解，我们也没有一本指南，即使我们尽最大努力做到最好。处于这种情境中确实会让人感到相当害怕。首先我想说明这一点，开门见山、首当其冲，因为你的每一个细胞都想要修复正在发生的事情。你看到了他们的痛苦。你想要摆脱它。你想要找到某种出路，但我们就是不知道该怎么做。而且有时
it's just not something that we're capable of, but we still want to be there for them and we still want to love them. And we probably still want the relationship to thrive and to survive despite what's going on. So today I want to give you seven of my biggest tips that I've learned from the people who have honestly showed up for me what I needed during times when my mental health wasn't great what I wish people had known, but also what they did really, really well. And also things that I've learned from the times when I've been the support system for someone else who is struggling. I feel like a lot of this comes down to personal experience, but also some of the psychologies, some of the more therapeutical recommendations. We're going to discuss the best
这并不是我们能力所及的事情，但我们仍然希望陪伴在他们身边，我们依然想要爱他们。尽管发生了这一切，我们可能仍然希望这段关系能够蓬勃发展并维持下去。所以今天我想给你分享我总结的七个最重要的建议，这些都是我从那些在我心理健康状况不佳、最需要帮助的时候真正陪伴在我身边的人身上学到的——我希望人们当时能知道什么，以及他们做得非常非常好的地方。还有就是自我作为支持系统去帮助其他苦苦挣扎的人时所学到的经验。我觉得这很大程度上归结于个人经验，但也包括一些心理学知识，以及一些更具治疗性的建议。我们将讨论最佳的
ways to educate yourself, to listen, to keep yourself well, how to communicate, how to advocate for your loved one. This is just like such an important topic for me, just because of the honestly egregious lack of resources that we typically have, but also because I think I would have benefited from this information at times, both in terms of how I would have wanted to communicate my needs to people, but also kind of wanting to know how to help someone that I love.
自我教育、倾听、保持自身健康、如何沟通以及如何为你的爱人发声的方法。对我而言，这绝对是一个非常重要的课题，不仅因为我们通常缺乏严重的资源，还因为我认为自己在某些时候会从中受益，无论是关于我如何想要向人们表达我的需求，还是某种程度上想要知道如何去帮助我所爱的人。
So I'm hoping that you can come back to this. This can kind of be a reference point for you when you're waiting through some tricky waters, trying to figure out the best way to go about things. We're going to keep this intro short and sweet. I realize that I've been kind of rambling for a while and just really get into what is useful here. Some practical advice, some useful reminders, some things that you may not know or you hadn't
所以我希望你们能再次回顾这一点。当你经历一些棘手的水域、试图找出处理事情的最佳方式时，这可以成为你的一个参考点。我们会让这个引言保持简短而甜蜜。我意识到自己已经啰嗦了一段时间，现在就直奔主题，谈谈这里有什么是有用的。一些切实的建议，一些有用的提醒，以及一些关于爱、支持、关心一个正在经历心理健康困境的人时，你可能并不了解或没有
thought about when it comes to loving, supporting, caring about someone who is going through it with their mental health. So without further ado, let's go. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs. when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness,
想过的事情。废话不多说，让我们开始吧。2%。这就是有电梯可乘时依然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析心理韧性、
fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory.
健身，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立恢复力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经坚信种子油本质上具有炎症性。
We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little kill?
我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题其实都是压力导致的。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在逆境之后变得更加快乐、更有成就感、更健康。请收听《2%》。也就是在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听“2”百分比播客。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上拍了两下小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不关心黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？
Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed.
好吧，你可以在《回顾过去》(Look Back at it)播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。在每一集中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。包括最近一期与马马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，大谈80年代的快克可卡因。需要说明的是，1984年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时都准备好聊一聊快克，但只是让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，此时此刻，这是我们第二集讨论了。
That's correct. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Then you're finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah.
没错。所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿始终的线索。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在了台面上。然后你接着说完了那句话。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。
For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests.
对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听“Look Back at it”。欢迎收听我的新播客《知难而退》(Learn the Hard Way)，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了致敬心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。
I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses.
我指的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时我们在追求某事时，会过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它，却还在继续追逐，并且不知道什么时候才算足够，因为人们都在盯着记分牌看。生活变成了关于输赢的较量。
Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keir Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing,
史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，你觉得在这个世界上活着做一个好人很重要吗？你做一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是的。这是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正做一个好人。和我（基尔·盖恩斯）一起，在我的新播客《知难而退》中，就疗愈、
growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free Our Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself, at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story.
成长、为人父、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你的免费iHeart Radio应用程序。搜索《知难而退》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己身处一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。
This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for.
这开启了一场长达多年的法庭之争，以证明真相。埃伦女士，你对这个特定的测试动了两次手脚，对吗？我只对测试动过一次手脚。这需要一支网络侦探大队才能破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。
Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。女同性恋者，迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我简直惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《受困于爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either.
随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《受困于爱》播客。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。法则一，永远不要惹乡村女孩。你在玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖励。法则二，也永远不要惹她的朋友。
We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I guess. got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart
我们总是说，相信你的好姐妹。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在《闺蜜》的新一季中，天哪，这是同一个男人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个惯犯骗子约会过。我感觉自己好像被卡车撞了。我想，这怎么可能发生在我身上呢？警察似乎并不在意。所以她们决定自己采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼的不会。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他会得到应有的下场。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts上收听《闺蜜，相信我，宝贝》
radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Let's talk through my five biggest pointers and pieces of advice that I give people when they ask me, how do I make life easier? for the person I love who is struggling with their mental health. Where exactly do I start? What do I do? The biggest thing you can do and the best place to start is to educate yourself. I know that sounds super, super simple, but it does involve a bit more than just reading a Wikipedia page
或任何你获取播客的地方。让我们来聊聊我的五个最重要的核心要点和建议，每当有人问我“如何让我所爱之人的生活变得更轻松？对于那些正在与心理健康作斗争的人，我究竟该从哪里开始？我该怎么做？”时，我都会把这些分享给他们。你做的最重要的事情，也是最好的起点，就是自我教育。我知道这听起来超级、超级简单，但它实际上需要做的不止是阅读一份维基百科页面
that lists the definition of anxiety or depression or OCD from the 1900s and like three to four symptoms. I want you to actually do some digging. What's the pathology? What's happening in their mind that creates, this reality for them. What's the biology? What are the reactions? The contributors. You know, I want you to be able to write me like a report on this. When they're panicking, when they're overstimulated, when they're coping with a depressive episode. What does that actually mean? What is
上面列出的20世纪的焦虑、抑郁或强迫症的定义，以及三到四个症状。我希望你们真正去进行一些深入挖掘。病理学是什么？在他们的头脑中发生了什么，从而为他们创造了这种现实？生物学是什么？反应是什么？诱因是什么？你知道的，我希望你能就此给我写一份报告。当他们恐慌时，当他们过度受刺激时，当他们正在应对抑郁发作时。这实际上意味着什么？什么是
the science? What is the psychology? Get as much information as you can. Firstly, so that you can act from an informed place. You can take on the thinking for them in a crisis or in a tough situation because you kind of know what is happening on a more neurological or on a more, I don't know, unconscious level. But secondly, sometimes feeling seen is really all that people want. You don't have to have the answers. It's just the fact that you tried and you went looking for them that is more than enough. From personal experience, I will say that it is so validating when the person you love takes time to understand all the things. things that make you, you, even the things that on a personal level are quite vulnerable and hard
科学？什么是心理学？尽可能多地获取信息。首先，这样你就能从一个知情的位置出发。在危机或艰难的处境中，你可以替他们进行思考，因为你大概知道在神经学层面上，或者在某种程度上，在无意识层面上正在发生什么。但其次，有时让人感到被看见才是人们真正想要的。你不需要拥有所有答案。仅仅是你尝试过去寻找答案，就已经足够了。根据个人经验，我要说的是，当你爱的人花时间去理解那些
to show people. Because oftentimes, I think the most exhausting thing to do in the moment when life is like really, really hard, you're in an episode, your symptoms are spiking, is to have to give a reason for why this is happening or to try and find the patience or the mental energy to explain step step by step, you know, what's occurring in your brain? What does this feel like? What's actually happening? So coming to the table, even with just knowledge, is already doing 50% of the work for them. I remember having a panic attack in front of a partner once, an ex-partner. And, you know, our relationship didn't end up, you know, it ended pretty poorly, I will say, but I will always remember this time, really, it's quite a special memory for me and I'm having this panic attack I'm really not doing well
构成真实的你的所有事物时，这种感觉是如此具有确认性，甚至包括那些在个人层面上相当脆弱、很难向他人展示的事物。因为通常情况下，我认为当生活变得非常、非常艰难、你正处于发作期、症状急剧恶化时，最让人筋疲力尽的事情，就是必须为这一切发生的原因给出一个理由，或者试图找到耐心或精神精力去一步一步地解释，你知道的，你的大脑中正在发生什么？这感觉像什么？实际上发生了什么？所以，带着哪怕只是一点点知识来到对话桌前，就已经替他们完成了50%的工作。我记得曾在前伴侣——一个前男友面前经历过一次恐慌发作。而且，你知道的，我们的关系并没有走到最后，（我会说）它的结局相当糟糕，但我永远会记得那段时光，实际上，这对我来说是一段非常特别的记忆，当时我正在经历恐慌发作，我的状态真的很不好，
and he like pulls out this explanation about what exactly is happening to my body and he like carefully and calmly explains it to me he explains the reactions in my amygdala he explains the noraphyran running through my veins and what my heart rate is doing and having all that information being presented to me quite rationally without having to call in it myself was so special and seeing how committed he was to really getting it and getting what I was going through was so soothing. Like I said, obviously we're no longer together and, you know, the relationship ended pretty poorly, but it is a pretty special memory. And it was definitely one of those times when my standards for friendship, for future relationships, for really everyone in my life, increased.
然后他掏出这样一段解释，说明我身体里究竟正在发生什么，他小心翼翼又冷静地向我解释。他向我解释了我杏仁核中的反应，他解释了在我血管中奔涌的去甲肾上腺素，以及我的心率正在发生的变化，所有这些信息都非常理性地呈现给我，而不需要我自己去呼唤它，这是如此特别。看到他如此致力于真正去理解它、理解我正在经历的事情，是如此具有抚慰作用。就像我说的，很显然我们已经不再在一起了，而且，你知道的，那段关系结束得相当糟糕，但这是一段相当特别的记忆。这绝对是那些让我对友谊、对未来关系、对生活中真正每个人的标准都大大提高的时刻之一。
I will say as much as scientific, almost textbook information and knowledge, it is really fantastic. and I think we could all really benefit from a deeper understanding of all the things that have flicked our brains. It is just the first step. Part of educating yourself also means listening to your partner when things have settled down, when the time is right, and when they have the mental space to teach you about their specific experience. There are things your partner can tell you about themselves and whatever is racing through their mind or impacting their reality that no one has ever written down before, that no one could know, that none of us could see because it is so individual. There really is no guidebook when it comes to caring and supporting someone you love
我想说，尽管科学的、几乎是教科书式的信息和知识非常棒，而且我认为我们都可以从对那些刺激我们大脑的事物的更深理解中真正受益，但这也只是第一步。自我教育的一部分还意味着，当事情平息下来、时机成熟并且你的伴侣有心理空间来教导你了解他们的具体经历时，去倾听你的伴侣。有些事情你的伴侣可以告诉你关于他们自己的事情，以及任何在他们脑海中飞驰或影响他们现实的事情，是以前从未有人写下来过的，是没有任何人能够知道的，是我们所有人都不可能看到的，因为它是如此个性化。当涉及到关心和支持你所爱的人时，真的没有一本通用的指南，
because mental health is truly different for everyone. Of course, here I am speaking about what you can do, but something that I really want to impress upon. you is that every person who is struggling with a mental illness, a mental condition, mental affliction, whatever it is, is going to experience that almost just insanely differently from the next person. There will be some general things that are the same. Obviously, there are criteria that you need to meet in order to be diagnosed. There is a general set of categories that people fall into.
因为心理健康对每个人来说确实都是不同的。当然，我在这里谈论的是你能做什么，但我真正想要向你强调的是，每一个正在与精神疾病、精神状况、精神折磨或任何类似事情作斗争的人，他们对这种状况的体验，与下一个人的体验相比，几乎会有着疯狂的不同。会存在一些大致相同的普遍事情。很显然，为了被诊断，你需要满足一些标准。人们会落入一个大致的类别集合中，
but if you were to take one person with, who had been diagnosed with depression and compared them to another person, it's still going to be different. You know, it's still going to have a different, this person's going to have a different origin story for, you know, the first time they experienced a depressive episode, they're going to have different sets of particularities or patterns of thoughts or ways of responding or behaviours. I really want us all to remember that our brains have, I think it's like, 25 quadrillion neural pathways. That is not even a number that any of us can comprehend.
但如果你把一个被诊断患有抑郁症的人与另一个人进行比较，情况依然会是不同的。你知道的，依然会有所不同，这个人会有一个不同的起源故事，（你知道的）关于他们第一次经历抑郁发作的经历，他们会有一套不同的特殊性、思维模式、反应方式或行为。我真的希望我们所有人都记住，我们的大脑拥有，我想大概是，25千万亿条神经通路。这甚至都不是我们任何人所能理解的数字。
It's more stars in the Milky Way, more people than will ever be on this earth. That is how many different connections and pathways are in each of our brains. So the same way that none of our personalities or our realities are the same, one person's experience with their mental health is going to be as unique as they are. get to know their story. This is when I want you to allow your girlfriend, your boyfriend, your loved one to be your source of truth. The online resources might say that anxiety or BPD looks one way.
这比银河系中的星星还要多，比将要在这个地球上存在的人还要多。这就是我们每个人大脑中存在的不同连接和通路的数量。因此，就像我们的任何个性和现实都不是完全相同的一样，一个人对心理健康问题的经历也将和他们本人一样独特。去了解他们的故事。这时我希望你允许你的女友、男友、你爱的人成为你的真理之源。网络资源可能会说焦虑或边缘型人格障碍看起来是某种样子的。
It might look irrational or highly explosive or whatever it says. But if they're saying to you, that doesn't describe my experience, trust their truth. Because generalizations and misjudging based on a limited definition or information is actually one of the main ways that we unintentionally uphold stigma, even if we don't mean to. Some general rules here for listening to someone's speak about such hard topics is to firstly be open to the moment. And when your partner decides that it's time to share, it's time to listen. And I know that sounds like kind of an impossible thing. Like, oh my gosh, like, what if I'm on my way to work? What if like something else is happening? I get that. But it is so hard to talk about mental
它可能看起来是不理智的、高度爆发性的，或者无论上面怎么说。但如果他们对你坦白：“这并不符合我的体验”，请相信他们的真理。因为根据有限的定义或信息进行的概括和错误判断，实际上是我们无意中助长污名化的主要方式之一，即使我们并非有意如此。这里有一些关于倾听某人谈论如此沉重话题的通用规则：首先是对当下保持开放。当你的伴侣决定是时候分享了，就是倾听的时候。我知道这听起来像是一件不可能做到的事情。就像，哦天哪，如果我正走在去上班的路上怎么办？如果发生了其他事情怎么办？我理解这一点。但谈论心理健康是如此艰难。
health. Even when you feel supported, even when you think that this person won't judge you, because we have been conditioned into staying silent about it, from everything to stereotypes, to the media, to personal experiences where we've been shut down, it is so difficult to kind of get the courage to be open about something so vulnerable. So if someone is opening up to you over text, in person, over the phone, if they are showing you this emotional side that you know is rare for them to reveal and that not any random person is privy to, that is a privilege. So please try not to move on to the next part of the conversation. Don't try and bury it.
即使你感到被支持，即使你认为这个人不会评判你，因为我们已经被刻板印象、媒体以及我们被拒绝的个人经历等一切因素进行过条件反射，变得对此保持沉默，要鼓起勇气对如此脆弱的事情保持坦诚是如此困难。所以，如果有人通过短信、当面、电话向你敞开心扉，如果他们向你展示了你知道对他们而言很罕见、且任何随机路人都无权知晓的这种情感一面，这是一种特权。所以请尽量不要急于跳到对话的下一个部分。不要试图将它掩盖过去。
Just be a sponge for a second. Just be a sponge and absorb. Sometimes you just don't know what to say and I get that discomfort. It's a very human discomfort to kind of be in the situation where you're like, oh, I know that this requires me to say something. I know I should be responding to them opening up, but I just, I don't. don't want to say the wrong thing. I get it. So I want you to remember the golden rule here is just to validate. Whatever they say, your response is one of validation. Either you say things like,
只需做一个海绵，哪怕一秒钟。只需做一个海绵，去吸收。有时你就是不知道该说些什么，我理解这种不适感。处于这样一种境地是一种非常人类的不适感——你心里会想：“哦，我知道这需要我说点什么。我知道我应该对他们敞开心扉做出回应，但我就是，我不想说错话。”我理解。所以我希望你记住这里的黄金法则就是去验证。无论他们说什么，你的回应都是一种验证。你要么说这样的话：
you know, that must be so typical. That makes sense why you're so upset about this. No, you're not overreacting. This is a tough situation. I'm here for you. Take your time. Have a few of those up your sleeve. Like literally just put it all back onto them and acknowledging their experience. ask questions that create that positive emotional space for them to share more. Things like, I want to hear more about that if you want to share. And what happened afterwards? How are you feeling now? That is the golden rule.
你知道的，那一定很典型。这就难怪你为此这么沮丧了。不，你并没有小题大做。这确实是个艰难的处境。我在这里陪着你。慢慢来。袖子里多准备几个这样的话。字面意思就是把一切都归回到他们身上，并承认他们的体验。提出能够为他们分享更多内容创造积极情感空间的问题。比如：如果你愿意分享的话，我想听听更多关于这方面的事。后来怎么样了？你现在感觉怎么样？这就是黄金法则。
Well, actually, there's two golden rules. So I guess a golden and a silver rule. The gold rule is to validate as much as possible. The silver rule, I guess, is just to listen more than you speak. And try not to insert yourself into what they're experiencing by comparing your experiences, interrupting, or I think worse but hardest of all, thinking that what they're going through always comes back to you, because a lot of the time, it doesn't. If someone is anxious, if someone is upset, frustrated, irritated, sometimes our tendency
嗯，实际上，有两个黄金法则。所以我想一个算是黄金法则，一个算白银法则。黄金法则就是尽可能多地进行验证。白银法则，我想，就是多听少说。并且尽量不要通过比较你的经历、打断对方，或者——我认为更糟但也是最难做到的一点——认为他们所经历的总是与你有关，来将你自己强加到他们的体验中，因为很多时候，并不是这样的。如果有人感到焦虑，如果有人感到心烦意乱、沮丧、恼火，有时我们的倾向
is to see their emotions and feel threatened by them. Like, oh, are they mad at me? Are they anxious about our relationship? Is this what it's all about? I get the inclination, just pause for a second. If it was about you, trust them to say something. People with mental health concerns can stand up for themselves. Like they're not weak or confused or deceitful or anything of the sort.
就是看到他们的情绪并感到被威胁。比如，哦，他们是在生我的气吗？他们是在为我们的关系焦虑吗？这就是这一切的全部原因吗？我理解这种倾向，但请暂停一下。如果这与你有关，相信他们会说出来的。有心理健康问题的人是可以为自己挺身而出的。就像他们并不脆弱、困惑、虚伪或任何类似的东西一样。
If it was about you, they would say so. But often you are part of the solution for them rather than the problem. That is why they are trusting you with this information. Because they see a future. They want you to know them deeply and intimately. So just try not to jump to conclusion. about what they're feeling or who or what it's towards. This brings me to my next point.
如果这与你有关，他们会直说的。但通常情况下，你是他们解决方案的一部分，而不是问题所在。这就是为什么他们把这些信息托付给你。因为他们看到了未来。他们希望你深刻而亲密地了解他们。所以请尽量不要对他们的感受、或者这种感受是针对谁或什么的妄下结论。这把我带到了我的下一个观点。
Don't always assume that you know what's best and instead really learn how they most like to be treated or helped through a tough moment because again it's very individual and it may be different to what you may need. The first instinct that we have when we see someone we love in pain, suffering, panicking is to immediately jump into action.
不要总是自以为你知道什么才是最好的，相反，真正去了解他们最喜欢在经历艰难时刻时被如何对待或如何获得帮助，因为同样地，这也是非常个性化的，并且可能与你所需要的有所不同。当我们看到我们爱的人在痛苦、受折磨、恐慌时，我们的第一直觉就是立刻采取行动。
That shows you have a deep bond when their pain is your pain, it's also reflective of the distance of these things called mirror neurons between you two, which are basically connections in your brain that match the connections in theirs on a neurological level. These mirror neurons were first observed actually in monkeys who had these really, really complex social bonds
这表明你们有着深厚的羁绊，当他们的痛苦就是你的痛苦时，这也反映了你们两个之间被称为“镜像神经元”的事物的距离，镜像神经元基本上就是你大脑中的连接在神经学层面上与他们大脑中的连接相匹配的桥梁。镜像神经元最初实际上是在猴子身上观察到的，这些猴子拥有非常、非常复杂的社会羁绊，
that meant that sometimes these primates could feel each other's pain, quite literally. But there was this groundbreaking research in 2020, only two years ago, which is such a short time when it comes to science. And it found these same neurons first identified in the monkeys were also present in you and I. The existence of mirror neurons means that when you see someone you love or you're connected to struggling, you will sometimes feel some of that same tension, stress, even sensory pain that they do. And this really makes you want to do something for both of your sakes.
这意味着有时这些灵长类动物可以字面意义上地感受到彼此的痛苦。但2020年有了一项突破性的研究，仅仅在两年前，就科学而言这是一个如此短暂的时间。研究发现，最初在猴子身上识别出的这些相同的神经元也同样存在于你我体内。镜像神经元的存在意味着，当你看到你爱的人或与你有关联的人在挣扎时，你有时也会感受到与他们相同的紧张、压力甚至感官痛苦。这真的会为了你们双方好而促使你去做点什么。
pause for a second. You might have all the love in the world, but there are just some things you can't fix, especially in the moment. So you don't need to be the solution for them. Just provide them with what they need most from you to help them get to, not even a place of looking for a solution themselves, but just to a place of surrendering and calm and peace. What do they need? What would they most want from you right now? And if you don't know, the easiest way is to ask, Some people prefer comfort. Some people prefer solutions, silence. They just want to be listened to.
但请暂停一下。你可能拥有世上所有的爱，但就是有些事情你是无法修复的，尤其是在当下。所以你不需要成为他们的解药。只需为他们提供他们此时最需要你的帮助，帮助他们到达一个甚至不需要他们自己去寻找解决方案的地方，而是到达一个顺从、平静和和平的地方。他们需要什么？此时此刻他们最想要你做什么？如果你不知道，最简单的方法就是去问。有些人更喜欢安慰。有些人更喜欢解决问题，或者保持沉默。他们只想被倾听。
Typically, the three things that people need most are known as the three H's. Do you want to be helped, held, or heard? Basically, just get to know your partner's processing language or style. The same way that we have a love language, most of us have an emotional processing language. Often it's a combination, but at different times, you do need different things. Do you need to be able to physically express what you're feeling? To creatively express what you're feeling. Do you prefer intellectualizing, problem solving, verbally talking it out?
通常，人们最需要的三件事被称为“三个H”（Helped, Held, Heard）。你想要得到帮助（helped）、被拥抱（held）还是被倾听（heard）？基本上，去了解你的伴侣的处理语言或风格。就像我们有爱的语言一样，我们大多数人都有情感处理语言。通常这是一个组合，但在不同的时间，你确实需要不同的东西。你需要能够身体力行地表达你的感受吗？以创造性的方式表达你的感受。你更喜欢将事物理性化、解决问题、通过言语将事情说出来吗？
Do you just need silence? That's sometimes something that I need. Get to know what is your partner's first way, or your friend or your loved one. What is the first way they like to go about a problem or something that they're going through? Is it just to sit with it themselves or is it to do something? let them kind of guide you in what is best for them because they do know themselves best in this situation and that means that they are actually going to get the support that they require from you. You know, I remember the story of like my friend going through a really, really rough time and
你只需要沉默吗？这有时是我所需要的。去了解你的伴侣的首选方式是什么，或者你的朋友或你爱的人的首选方式是什么。他们处理问题或经历的事情的首选方式是什么？是自己默默消化，还是做点什么？让他们引导你了解什么对他们来说是最好的，因为在这种情况下他们确实最了解自己，这意味着他们实际上将从你那里获得他们所需的支撑。你知道的，我记得我的一位朋友经历过一段非常、非常艰难的时期，
her boyfriend like clean their house, did the dishes, did the groceries. So lovely from him, right? And she was like, I don't know why, but I was so frustrated about that because in my mind, I was coming home and I wanted to have control over the situation and I wanted to do those chores. That was going to be a way for me to work through the problems in my brain by working through the things that needed to be done in the house. Like that control was really what I needed in that moment and he kind of took that away from me. You would never know that, right? You would never know that.
她的男友把他们的房子打扫干净了，洗了盘子，去买好了杂货。从他角度来看这真是太可爱了，对吧？而她说：“我不知道为什么，但我对此感到非常沮丧，因为在我的脑海里，我回到家时是想要对这种情况有控制权的，我想要自己做那些家务。这将是我通过处理屋里需要做的事情来解决我大脑中问题的一种方式。那种控制感正是我在那一刻真正需要的，而他某种程度上把它从我身边夺走了。”你永远不会知道这一点，对吧？你永远不会知道。
He obviously was doing what he thought was best. But sometimes the most meaningful thing is not what you think is best. it's what the person actually requires. And I know that it's just like the most simple principle, but I think it's an important reminder to just ask. Honestly, you can also make a list in your notes up to remind you of what moods, what situations require what from you, both from conversations with them and also from noticing things in the moment.
他显然在做他认为最好的事。但有时最有意义的事情并不是你认为最好的事，而是那个人真正需要的。我知道这只是一个最简单的原则，但我认为这是一个重要的提醒，那就是去问问。老实说，你还可以在备忘录里列一个清单，提醒自己什么情绪、什么情况需要你做出什么样的反应，这些既来自于与他们的对话，也来自于当下的观察。
For me, I have a list for myself when I'm panicking or just overwhelmed with anxiety or going through like a real, you know, downpier. in my life. I have this list of like, it's almost up to 20 things that I know I can do, that I know I would need or could help. Progressive muscle relaxation is one of them, calling my boyfriend and talking it out, taking a big walk in nature, listening to a guide of meditation. And what's really, really valuable to me is that my partner has a similar one of like, okay, if this is what's happening, this is what we need to do. This is like a plan of attack. it's like an individualized guidebook.
对我来说，当我恐慌或被焦虑压得喘不过气来、或者经历生活中真正的（你知道的）低谷期时，我为自己准备了一个清单。我有一个像这样的清单，上面列了多达20件我知道自己能做的事、我知道自己需要或能提供帮助的事。渐进式肌肉放松就是其中之一，给男友打电话把事情说出来，去大自然中进行一次长途散步，听一个引导式冥想。对我而言真正非常有价值的是，我的伙伴也有一个类似的清单，上面写着：“好吧，如果发生了这种情况，这就是我们需要做的。这就像是一个攻击计划。”它就像一本个性化的指南。
And I think like we are at this stage in our relationship where he knows that if I'm having a really, really rough time, I really don't want to hear a solution from him. I really don't need him problem solving for me as kind and beautiful and lovely as that is. I actually need to be present in the crisis and fix it myself. So him coming in and suggesting things is just overwhelming and stressful. That is my perspective. that is what I need, but for other people, they really do need that rational voice outside of their head to say something and to help them through whatever it is they're going through.
我认为我们处于这样一种关系阶段：他知道如果我正在经历一段非常、非常艰难的时期，我是真的不想听到他提出解决方案。尽管那样做既善良、美好又可爱，但我真的不需要他为我解决问题。我实际上需要身处危机之中并靠自己解决它。所以他插手并提出建议只会让我感到不知所措和压力山大。这是我的观点，这就是我所需要的，但对其他人来说，他们确实需要脑海之外那个理性的声音来说点什么，并帮助他们度过他们正在经历的任何事情。
So just try not to infantize your partner. This is something I see a lot and I get people complaining about it to me a lot. Like, why does my boyfriend treat me like I'm stupid just because I'm anxious? Why is everyone always asking me if I'm okay? Like, I'm a little child. Why does my boss always speak to me in hushed tones? why do people just take over parts of my life thinking that I don't know how to do it? Infantilization really occurs when people with mental health concerns feel like
所以请尽量不要把你的伴侣当作幼儿看待。这是我经常看到的一种现象，而且经常有人向我抱怨这一点。比如：“为什么我男友仅仅因为我焦虑就把我当成傻子？”“为什么每个人总是问我是否还好？就像我是个小孩子一样。”“为什么我老板总是用压低的声音跟我说话？”“为什么人们总是接管我生活中的部分内容，认为我不知道该怎么做？”当有心理健康问题的人觉得
because their brain works differently, they suddenly are seen as less capable or knowledgeable about their own condition and their own life. People become overprotective. They misjudge what they're able to do and they think they know better, which also contributes to that unsolicited advice giving we spoke about earlier or trying to problem solve their lives to them when actually they can do it themselves if you give them the support and the safety net and the structures around that.
因为他们的大脑工作方式不同，他们突然被视为对自己状况和生活的理解能力或知识储备不足时， infantilization（幼稚化）就真正发生了。人们变得过于保护。他们错误地判断了对方能做什么，并认为自己知道得更多，这也助长了我们之前谈到的主动给出不请自来的建议的现象，或者是试图为他们解决生活中的问题，而实际上如果你给予他们支持、安全网和周围的结构，他们自己就能做到这一点。
Basically, just don't treat your partner or your loved one like a child and you should be all good. You should continue to have a respectful two-way relationship. Okay, we are going to take a short break, but when we return, we'll discuss the three final pieces of advice. I have for you when you're supporting someone who is struggling. Don't go anywhere. Stay with us.
基本上，只要不把你的伴侣或你爱的人当成小孩子对待，你就一切都好了。你应该继续保持一种尊重的人际关系。好了，我们要稍作休息，但当我们回来时，我们将讨论我给你的最后三条建议，这些建议是关于你如何支持一个正在挣扎的人。不要去任何地方。和我们在一起。
We'll be back after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more
我们在短暂的休息后会回来。2%。这就是有电梯可乘时依然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中。我将剖析心理韧性、健身，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立恢复力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话
to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-P-P-Cent on the I-Hart Radio. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs?
忽视那些充斥在健康产业中不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾深信种子油天生会引发炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听 2%。这就是 iHeartRadio 上的 T-W-O-P-P-Cent。苹果播客，或任何你收听播客的地方。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在 VMA 颁奖典礼上双击小金的胸部吗？
Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at It podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在 Look Back at It 播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。在每期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何挺过那段时光的。
Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence.
其中包括最近一期邀请了马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，畅谈 80 年代的快克毒品。坦白说，84 年对我意义重大，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时都可以聊聊快克，只是想让大家知道我的态度。我是说，马克，这是我们第二期讨论快克了。所以我开始看出其中的脉络了。我们现在还在讨论艾滋病。谢谢你把话说完。
Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games.
是的。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。请在 IHeartRadio 应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听 Look Back at It。欢迎来到我的新播客《用难忘的方式学习》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们的主持人，也是你们最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。
And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch.
为了响应心理健康意识月，我带来了我自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多杰出嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时我们在追求某事时，会过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它，却依然在追逐，而且我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是在看记分牌。
Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust.
生活变成了赢与输的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在世上做一个好人很重要，还是你做一个好人只是因为你害怕？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。而且这是两个不同层次的信任。
I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free I Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now.
我希望你们能真正做一个好人。和我（基尔·盖恩斯）一起，在我的新播客《用难忘的方式学习》中，就治愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的 I Heart Radio 应用。搜索“Learn the Hard Way”并立即收听。
In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. L.E.
2023 年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己陷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻中。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了他故事中惊人的矛盾之处。这就开始了长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。你篡改了这个特定的测试两次，L.E. 女士。
I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detection. detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gregalespian and Michael Marantini.
我篡改测试一次。这需要一支互联网侦探大队来破案。我希望人们能看到他们的税款被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona.
我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。
Listen to a love-trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man.
在 IHeartRadio 应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。规则一，千万不要惹乡下女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也绝对不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在《女朋友们》这个新季节里，天哪，这是同一个男人。
A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care, so they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends.
一群女性发现她们都和同一个高产的骗子约会过。我觉得我被卡车撞了。我想，这怎么可能发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在乎，所以她们决定自己动手。我说，哦，见鬼不。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的。收听《女朋友们》。
Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. There is something so beautiful about someone who respects your lived reality enough to defend it even when you're not around. There is something really, really beautiful about someone who doesn't ignore your experiences and what you're going through even though it's not directly impacting them. if you want to be a supportive partner, a supportive loved one, think about how you speak about mental health when they're not around. Changing stigma, changing prejudice, advocating for mental
相信我，宝贝。在 Iheart radio 应用、苹果播客或任何你收听播客的地方。当一个人尊重你的现实生活，甚至在你不在场时也为你辩护，这真的是一件非常美好的事情。当一个人不会忽视你的经历和你所经历的事情，即使这并不直接影响他们，这真的是非常非常美好的事情。如果你想成为一个支持性的伴侣、一个支持性的挚爱之人，想一想当他们不在场时你是如何谈论心理健康的。消除污名化，消除偏见，倡导心理
health to be seen and to be respected can't just be in the hands of the people who are struggling. It's also up to the people who love them to really spark meaningful, positive change to challenge their own beliefs and the beliefs of those around them, just to make the world a little bit safer. If you hear someone say something that's just plain wrong, say so. If you witness a policy in your workplace that you know would make it harder for someone like the person you love to show up in their job or career, say something. You know, if a relative is deliberately being bigoted or judgmental, say something. that is in part your responsibility. I think make the world a little bit softer and gentler
健康应该被看到和尊重，这不能仅仅依靠那些正在苦苦挣扎的人们。这也取决于那些爱他们的人，去真正引发有意义的积极改变，去挑战他们自己的信念以及周围人的信念，只为了让这个世界变得更安全一点。如果你听到有人说了一些明显错误的话，那就说出来。如果你在工作场所看到一项政策，你知道这会让你爱的人这样的人更难在他们的工作或职业中展现自我，那就说点什么。你知道，如果一个亲戚故意表现得偏执或评判他人，那就说点什么。这在某种程度上是你的责任。我认为让世界变得更柔软、更温和
for your loved one to enter. I think in those moments when you stand up, you speak out, you challenge what people might incorrectly believe or assume. You're not just defending your loved one. You're also kind of paving away for a future where they don't have to fight those battles themselves and that, you know, where they can be open and vulnerable about what they're going through. you're basically just helping create a society where there is, you know, where mental health is treated with the same importance and dignity as physical health. And I think your actions are a really powerful message, not just to the world, but to the people around you to your close circle who probably also interact with your loved one, that mental health matters. It's not something to be swept under the rug. It's not something to kind of cringe away from and be like, oh, that's uncomfortable.
让你爱的人步入其中。我想在那些你挺身而出、大声疾呼、挑战人们可能错误相信或假设的时刻。你不仅仅是在保护你爱的人。你也是在为未来铺平道路，让他们不必自己去打那些仗，你知道的，让他们可以公开、脆弱地表达他们正在经历的事情。你基本上只是在帮助创建一个社会，在那里，你知道的，心理健康被赋予与身体健康同等的重要性和尊严。我认为你的行动是一个非常强有力的信息，不仅向世界传达，也向你周围的人、你的核心圈子传达——他们可能也与你爱的人互动——心理健康很重要。这不是一件可以扫到地毯底下的事情。这不是那种让你退缩并觉得“哦，这很不舒服”的事情。
that's strange. I don't want to, you know, it's like contagious. I don't want anything to do about it. You're being very clear. Like, no, this is worth defending. I'm going to speak about this. I care about this. And it deserves your respect. In doing so, I think you just really contribute to a culture, a culture of empathy and a culture of understanding. And it's one of those most beautiful acts of love and true organic support. I just think it's one of the most gorgeous things that you can do is to say, you know, I'm not just going to support you in private. I'm going to advocate for you in public, whatever that means. It also has the secondary consequence impact, I guess, of making it feel like you're doing something
“这很奇怪。我不想，你知道的，就像传染病一样。我不想和它有任何关系。”你表现得非常明确。就像，不，这值得捍卫。我要谈论这个。我关心这个。它值得你的尊重。通过这样做，我认为你真的为一种文化做出了贡献，一种同理心的文化，一种理解的文化。这是最美丽的爱之行为和真正有机的支持之一。我只是觉得你能做的最华丽的事情之一就是说，你知道的，我不仅会在私下支持你。无论这意味着什么，我都会在公开场合为你辩护。它还有一个次要的后果影响，我想，那就是让你觉得你在做些什么
when sometimes there's nothing that you can really do for them in the sense that you can't cure their mental health. You can't always fix this problem, but you can make the world and the systems that are in place around mental health more accessible. less discriminatory, less stigmatized. So I do think that you get purpose from it. Even better, you get a sense of agency, productivity, progress, you feel like you are doing something for this person you love when sometimes you can feel quite powerless in the face of a very private battle with mental health. So that's tip number three. For this next tip, we are actually going to take a step back from your partner, the person you love for just a second. And for, focus on you. I want to validate you for just a moment. Seeing someone struggle elicits a lot of
而有时你真的无法为他们做任何事情，因为你无法治愈他们的心理健康问题。你不能总是解决这个问题，但你可以让围绕心理健康的现实世界和系统变得更容易接近。减少歧视，减少污名化。所以我确实认为你可以从中获得目标感。更好的是，你会获得一种能动性、生产力、进步感，你会觉得你正在为你所爱的人做些什么，而面对与心理健康的非常私密的斗争时，有时你会感到相当无力。所以这是第三个小贴士。对于下一个小贴士，我们实际上要从你的伴侣、你爱的人身上退一步，只需要一秒钟。然后，专注于你。我想认可你一会儿。看到有人挣扎会引发很多
weird, confusing feelings in us. Guilt that we can't fix the pain, sometimes an assumption of responsibility for their mental health. Exhaustion, stress for them, for their well-being, for their safety, and it can take its toll. I know that you would do it no matter what. I know that you probably don't feel like a hero for just loving someone the way that they should be loved. there's really no like special award for that. But there have been some really important studies showing that when we tend to take on a lot of what our partner is feeling and managing, that can really bleed into our own emotional state. And it can impact our mood, our ability to cope, our sense of optimism for the future.
在我们心中产生奇怪、混乱的感觉。无法修复痛苦的内疚感，有时还会承担起对他们心理健康的责任。疲惫，为他们、为他们的幸福、为他们的安全感到压力，这会付出沉重的代价。我知道你无论如何都会这么做。我知道，仅仅因为以应有的方式去爱一个人，你可能并不觉得自己是个英雄。对此真的没有什么特殊的奖励。但有一些非常重要的研究表明，当我们倾向于承担很多伴侣的感受和管理时，这确实会渗透到我们自己的情绪状态中。它会影响我们的情绪、应对能力、对未来的乐观态度。
And it can be really hopeless at times. And the complicated thing with mental health is that the person experiencing it feels it alone. It is an isolated experience. You cannot take the pain from your brain and put it on the table and let people touch it and feel it and understand what it feels like for you. But you also do have to watch them struggle and you probably have your own anxiety and worries about them that you end up managing alone. You may even be dealing with your own mental health. So as much as you want to be there everything, you want to find the magic cure. As much as you want to help, sometimes you just can't, and you need to fill your own cup.
有时这会让人感到非常绝望。而心理健康复杂的地方在于，经历它的人是独自感受它的。这是一种孤立的体验。你不能把大脑里的痛苦拿出来放在桌子上，让别人触摸它、感受它、理解它对你来说是什么感觉。但你也不得不看着他们挣扎，你可能对他们有自己的焦虑和担忧，最终只能独自应对。你甚至可能正在处理你自己的心理健康问题。所以，尽管你想成为一切，你想找到神奇的解药。尽管你想帮忙，但有时你就是做不到，你需要先照顾好自己。
It's like they always say this on planes. Put on your own mask before helping others. Sometimes we can get so concerned and wound up in someone else's internal conflicts and pain that we drop off of our own self-care practices, and we stop pouring energy in our own lives. So that's really tip number four. Time and space for yourself is a non-negotiable. and I want you and your partner to be on the same page about that. Whether it's, you know, an afternoon, a day just for you, whether you have boundaries around,
就像他们在飞机上常说的那样。在帮助他人之前，先戴好你自己的面罩。有时我们可能会过于关注和纠缠于他人的内心冲突和痛苦中，以至于我们放弃了自我照顾的做法，停止向我们自己的生活注入能量。所以这真的是第四个小贴士。时间和空间留给自己是不可协商的。我希望你和你的伴侣在这方面达成共识。无论是，你知道的，一个下午，一个只属于你的日子，无论你是否有界限，
when you can kind of take on the mental load, basically I think any point where you feel extreme tension, you feel things tearing, you feel yourself getting really, really stressed, or you feel like your relationship isn't working, that is where a boundary is required. Discomfort is the biggest indicator that a boundary is needed in that. space. Sometimes that feels really, really hard when you just love them so much and you don't want to let them down, you don't want to say no, you don't want to make them feel silenced. But it does actually mean that taking space for yourself now means you can continue to show up for them into the future. It's also really worthwhile, I think, having a confidant yourself, whether that's a therapist, a sibling, an anonymous
当你能承担心理负担时，基本上我认为在任何你感到极度紧张、感到事情在撕裂、感到自己变得非常非常压力山大，或者觉得你的关系无法运作的时候，这就是需要设置界限的地方。不适感是某个空间需要界限的最大指标。有时当你太爱他们而不想让他们失望时，这感觉真的非常非常难，你不想说不，你不想让他们感到被剥夺了发声的权利。但这实际上意味着现在为自己腾出空间意味着你可以继续在未来为他们出现。我认为，拥有一个你自己的知己也非常值得，无论是治疗师、兄弟姐妹、匿名的
support group, a really trusted friend. And the thing is, is that you don't have to go into like extreme detail of like yeah my girlfriend jenny like this is exactly what happened at 2 p.m last yesterday afternoon and this is the medication she's taking and this is her entire history her mental health history you don't have to do that you can focus on how the situation is making you feel and you can get the support that you require a reminder i think that it's not selfish to know your limits. It's not selfish to know how much you are able to take on what you can and can't carry. In fact, I think it's incredibly self-aware and loving to know what works for you and to want to be able to care and love your friend, your sibling, your partner, your mom, whoever it is
支持小组，还是一个非常值得信赖的朋友。关键是，你不需要陷入极度细致的细节中，比如“是的，我女朋友珍妮，昨天下午 2 点发生的正是这件事，这是她吃的药，这是她的整个病史，她的心理健康史”——你不需要这样做。你可以专注于这种情况带给你怎样的感受，并获得你所需要的支持。一个提醒，我认为了解自己的极限并不是自私的。知道自己能承担多少，能背负和不能背负什么，这并不是自私的。事实上，我认为知道什么对自己有效，并希望能够照顾和爱你的朋友、兄弟姐妹、伴侣、妈妈，无论他是谁，这都是非常具有自我觉察和充满爱意的表现。
for as long as possible without that taking a toll on you and your relationship or minimizing the toll that it can take on your relationship. This may also be hard to hear, and I know some people might not like me for saying this, but it's also okay to leave the relationship when you are noticing an effect on your own mental health. When their mental health is creating behaviours that aren't okay, that are unhealthy for you or for them, even if, you know, it isn't something that they can control. Because I think feeling obligated to stay just because of their mental health or feeling guilty for leaving as the real. and the motivation for staying. Firstly, it creates a really unbalanced dynamic in your relationship of like, well, I'm only staying with you because of your mental health. It's kind of like, well, you have no incentive to improve because then I'll leave you, if you get what I'm saying. So it's
尽可能长时间地维持下去，而不会对你和你们的关系造成损害，或者尽量减少它对你们关系可能造成的损害。这可能也很难听到，而且我知道有些人可能不会因为我这么说而喜欢我，但当你注意到它对你自己的心理健康产生影响时，离开这段关系也是可以的。当他们的心理健康导致了不好的行为，对你或对他们来说是不健康的，即使，你知道的，这并不是他们所能控制的。因为我认为仅仅因为他们的心理健康而感到有义务留下来，或者因为离开而感到内疚，是留下来真正的动机。首先，这会在你们的关系中造成一种非常不平衡的动态，比如，“嗯，我留下来完全是因为你的心理健康。”这有点像，“好吧，你没有任何动力去改善，因为那样我就会离开你，”如果你明白我的意思的话。所以这是
unbalanced, first of all, but also it's just not a great foundation for a relationship to survive or for either of you to get better or to even, you know, be the better versions of yourself. to be happy if the relationship is creating a really terrible cycle for both of you. So it is okay to leave. Make the decision that is right for you. And then you can start thinking, you know, what supports do they have in place? How do I deliver this kindly? When would be the best time to talk about this?
首先，这是不平衡的，而且它也不是一段关系得以存续、或者你们两个能够变得更好、甚至，你知道的，成为更好的自己的绝佳基础。如果这段关系为你们俩创造了一个非常糟糕的循环，那就无法获得快乐。所以离开是可以的。做出对你来说正确的决定。然后你可以开始思考，你知道的，他们有什么支持系统？我该如何友善地表达这一点？什么时候是谈论这个的最佳时机？
Who should maybe know beforehand if that's also a consideration? I know it's a really hard decision, but you're not a bad person for private. prioritizing your health and your well-being, first and foremost, because otherwise you have two people who are just not doing very well, and that's more that I think a relationship can sometimes take on. I want to give you all some final rapid fire tips that I hope stick in your brain for when you most need them as someone supporting someone you love with their mental health. first up, never give ultimatums as much as this may be hard for you. Trust me, they know, they know what you're feeling, probably 10 times what you're going
如果这也是一个需要考虑的因素，谁应该事先知道？我知道这是一个非常艰难的决定，但你优先考虑自己的健康和福祉并不是一个坏人，因为否则你们会有两个人状态都不是很好，我认为这超出了有时一段关系所能承受的极限。我想给你们所有人一些最后快速的小提示，我希望这些能留在你们的大脑中，当你们作为支持你们所爱之人的心理健康的人最需要它们时派上用场。首先，永远不要发出最后通牒，不管这对你来说有多难。相信我，他们知道，他们知道你的感受，可能比你经历的感受多十倍。
through. And if they could make it all go away, if that was an option, they would have done it a long time ago and in a heartbeat. And that's not to say that mental illness is like a disease for which we should only be looking for a cure. But what I'm saying is that this is something that people can't necessarily change. It's wired into their brain. and so asking them to fix it, asking them to get better within a short period of time,
如果他们能让这一切消失，如果那是一个选项，他们很久以前就会毫不犹豫地做了。这并不是说精神疾病就像一种我们应该只寻求治愈的疾病。但我想说的是，这是人们不一定能改变的事情。它是他们大脑中生来就有的。因此，要求他们解决这个问题，要求他们在短时间内好起来，
to get it all together, to find some way through, you know, it's basically the equivalent of saying, actually just hide this for me to make my life easier. So I don't have to deal with it. Rather than let's find a way of coping and healing together. Let's let this experience make us stronger, know you that you can lean on me. And Ultimate and basically just says, you know, yeah, cure yourself, fix yourself. but actually that's not an option so lie to me about it and conceal things from me, which is not necessarily, or even a tiny bit, healthy.
把一切都整理好，找到某种出路，你知道的，这基本上等同于说：“实际上，为了让我的生活更轻松，请把这个藏起来。这样我就不用去应付它了。”而不是“让我们一起找到应对和治愈的方法。让我们让这种经历使我们更强大，知道你可以依靠我。”最后通牒基本上只是说：“是的，治愈你自己，修复你自己。”但实际上这不是一个选项，所以对我撒谎并向我隐瞒事情，这不一定，甚至一点也不健康。
Secondly, know when it's too much for the both of you and outside help is needed. This probably, now that I'm thinking about it, should have been tip number one. But even therapists, even psychiatrists, even the most skilled, educated, wise people in the world do not act as the physicians or the psychologists for their family members or their friends or their partners because they know that the help that is needed goes beyond them. You need a neutral, trained third party to be a confidant, to offer support, assistance. You need something and someone beyond you. You just can't be everything, but you can be the one who encourages them to get the help they need
其次，知道什么时候对你们俩来说都太多了，需要外界的帮助。现在回想起来，这本该是第一条建议。但即使是治疗师、精神病学家、世界上最有技术、受过最高教育、最聪明的人，也不会充当他们家庭成员、朋友或伴侣的医师或心理学家，因为他们知道所需的帮助超出了他们的能力范围。你需要一个中立的、训练有素的第三方作为知己，提供支持和协助。你需要超越你自身的力量和人。你不可能成为万能的，但你可以成为鼓励他们寻求所需帮助的那个人，
because there is trust in your relationship. They're going to feel safe enough to take the next step. They're going to feel safe in the fact that you're the one encouraging them and you wouldn't do anything that's going to, you know, hurt them. Therapy is really, really hard if you've never been before. And even when you have been before, like, it's a tricky experience. It's hard being so open with someone at the beginning, especially since, you know, I think a therapist's client relationship requires a lot of trust.
因为你们的关系中存在信任。他们会感到足够安全，从而迈出下一步。他们会因为你是那个鼓励他们的人而感到安全，而且你不会做任何会，你知道的，伤害他们的事。如果你以前从未去过，心理治疗真的非常非常难。即使你以前去过，这也是一次棘手的经历。刚开始时对一个人如此坦诚是很困难的，尤其是因为，你知道的，我认为治疗师与客户的关系需要大量的信任。
And trust is mainly a product of time. So at the very beginning, it can feel awkward to talk to a stranger, basically, about things that you may have only ever told a partner or loved ones, but there is a good reason why everyone recommends therapy and why you should go. Because, to be honest, it works. If it's something that is accessible to you, I really, really would recommend it. Finally, make time to still have a relationship, even if that means adjustments. Your love has kind of got to exist through this and love does take effort. The hardest thing, one of the hardest things that I've recognized for people who have relationships in which one of them is dealing with their mental health
而信任主要是时间的产物。所以在最开始的时候，和一个基本上是陌生人的谈论你可能只跟伴侣或亲人倾诉过的事情，会让人觉得很尴尬，但每个人都推荐心理治疗以及你应该去是有充分理由的。因为，老实说，它管用。如果这是你可以接触到的资源，我真的非常非常推荐。最后，抽出时间继续经营你们的关系，即使这意味着做出调整。你们的爱必须在这种情况下存续下去，而且爱确实需要付出努力。最难的事情之一，我为那些其中一人正在处理心理健康问题的伴侣关系所认识到的最难的事情之一，
is to find a way to still actively date each other, even if that looks differently. Mental health is always going to be part of your dynamic. It might come and go and sometimes be a lot quieter than at other times, but it's still going to be present the same way that a physical injury, a physical illness, a physical condition would be, and I don't want that to be a scary thing for you. I want you to remember why you're together, even in dark times. I want you to still love and celebrate this person and be celebrated yourself. I still want you to make memories that bond you and actively date each other so that this connection between you two only becomes stronger throughout everything that you're going through.
就是找到一种方法，仍然积极地约会，即使看起来可能有所不同。心理健康将永远是你们互动动态的一部分。它可能会来来去去，有时比其他时候安静得多，但它仍然会存在，就像身体损伤、身体疾病、身体状况一样，我不希望这是一件让你感到害怕的事。我希望你记住你们为什么在一起，即使在黑暗的时期也是如此。我希望你们仍然爱并庆祝这个人，同时也庆祝你自己。我仍然希望你们创造能够将你们联系在一起的回忆，并积极约会，这样你们两个之间的联系才会通过你们所经历的一切而变得更加强大。
You know, full-on date nights might not always be on the cards. there may be times when we're at capacity, we need space, we need a night in, you don't want to socialise, but find a night, a morning, a weekend every now and again when you focus on what's in the future, you focus on you two, you focus on what's good, and you nurture the connection that is, you know, the reason you're listening to this episode, because you love them and because you care about them and because you want them to get better, to feel better, to get back on their feet, and I guess you also just want your love to last. You want to do what's best by them. And I think that that is a really beautiful commitment and a sign of commitment to your relationship.
你知道的，全套的约会之夜可能并不总在计划之中。有时我们精疲力竭，需要空间，需要一个宅家之夜，你不想社交，但偶尔找一个晚上、一个早晨、一个周末，专注于未来，专注于你们两个，专注于美好的事物，去培育那种联系，你知道的，这也是你收听这一集的理由，因为你爱他们，因为你关心他们，因为你希望他们好起来，感觉好起来，重新振作起来，我想你也就是希望你们的爱能够持久。你想为他们做最好的事。我认为这是一个非常美丽的承诺，也是对你们关系的承诺的标志。
I will also say, I know I just said, that's my final thing, but one more thing, you're not always going to get everything right. And I just want to give you the permission that you need right now for that to be the case. Even, you know, me, someone who talks about mental health twice a week, daily, probably like every single day I talk about mental health. I have mental health problems with my own. I have family members with mental health problems. There are still times when I'm just like, I really don't know what to say in this situation and I'm probably going to say the wrong thing, do the wrong thing. But it's okay if you're doing it earnestly and from a place of genuine curiosity and care. Not everyone, I think the thing to say about this is that mental health
我还要说，我知道我刚才说过那是我的最后一件事，但还有一件事，你并不总是能把所有事情都做好。我只想给你现在需要的许可，让这种情况发生。即使，你知道的，像我这样每周谈论心理健康两次、每天都谈论的人，可能几乎每天我都在谈论心理健康。我也有我自己的心理健康问题。我有家人也有心理健康问题。仍然有时我会觉得：“在这种情况下我真的不知道该说什么，我可能会说错话，做错事。”但如果你是真诚地、从真正的好奇心和关怀出发去做的，那就没关系。每个人，我想关于这一点要说的是，心理健康
is really, really complicated that even the people who are experiencing it don't always know what's going on. So the fact that you don't know what's going on either means that you're probably in the same boat. So just give yourself some grace and some forgiveness to just try and when in doubt, like we said, golden rule, validate, listen, love. And you'll be doing just fine. So thank you so much for listening to this episode if you got this far. I hope that you learned something. I hope that you feel more equipped to show up in this situation, to provide kindness and love and care to this person that you love. And yeah, if there's someone else that you think needs to hear this episode, please feel free to share with them. Make sure that if you did enjoy this, leave us a five-star review
真的非常非常复杂，以至于连正在经历它的人也并不总是知道发生了什么。所以你也不知道发生了什么，这意味着你们很可能在同一条船上。所以，给自己一些宽容和原谅去尝试吧，当有疑问时，就像我们说的，黄金法则：确认、倾听、爱。你就会做得很好。非常感谢你收听到这一集，如果你听到了这里。我希望你学到了一些东西。我希望你觉得自己更有能力在这种情况下挺身而出，向你爱的人提供善良、爱和关怀。是的，如果你觉得还有其他人需要听这一集，请随时与他们分享。如果你真的很喜欢，请务必在 Apple Podcasts、Spotify 或你现在收听的任何地方给我们留下五星好评。如果你有什么想分享的，如果你有更多的建议、更多的提示、任何你心中的想法，请务必在 Instagram 上关注我们 @That Psychology podcast，你可以在那里分享你的想法、感受、对后续节目的请求、对其他主题的请求。再次感谢你的收听。直到下次，保持安全，保持善良，对你自己温柔一点。我们很快就会再聊。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯斯特。在我的播客节目 2% 中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能训练以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。
on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you're listening right now. And if you have something you want to share, if you have more pointers, more tips, anything that's on your mind, make sure you are following us at That Psychology podcast on Instagram, and you can share your thoughts, feelings, requests for a follow-up episode, requests for another topic over there. Again, thank you for listening. And until next time, stay safe, stay kind, and be gentle with yourself. We will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the side. of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听 2%。这就是 iHeartRadio 应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方的 TWO percent。在 Look Back at it 播客中。从 1979 年开始，这对我是个大时刻。84 年对我意义重大。我是萨姆·J。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam J.
我是亚历克斯·英格利士。在每期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜欢的作家一起，试着理解我们是如何挺过那段时光的。就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论 80 年代一样。那是个疯狂的年代。那是个疯狂的年代。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的一年了。请在 IHeartRadio 应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听 Look Back at It。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it, with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
你正在收听的是由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯主持的《用难忘的方式学习》。这个空间关乎黑人群体的经历，进行坦诚的对话，这些对话在其他任何地方其实都不安全，但你是在与一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人背负着一副盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这么做，请在 AHA 广播应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《用难忘的方式学习》。2023 年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕，
You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kier Games. This space is about black men. experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor Star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy,
似乎是一场骗局。你篡改了这个特定的测试两次，欧文斯女士，对吗？我篡改测试一次。这需要一支互联网侦探大队来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。
appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在 IHeartRadio 应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听 Love Trapped 播客。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个高产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己动手。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。
This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target.
他绝对不会就这么逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友。收听《女朋友们》。
He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHeart podcast.
相信我，宝贝。在 IHeartRadio 应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方。这是一档 IHeart 播客。
Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
保证真人。本集还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。